things and as if things couldn't get any
worse joe biden's afghanistan disaster
seems to be bleeding over stateside
arizona's attorney general warning that
terrorists released by the taliban could
be sneaking into our country amid the
chaos at the border
this threat comes as the bud
administration was dealt a huge blow to
their immigration plans the supreme
court reinstating former president
trump's remain in mexico policy for
asylum seekers the policy that requires
applicants to wait in mexico while their
claims are evaluated by american
authorities all right so dana say a
taliban evacuee gets to mexico do you
think that taliban person's going to
remain in mexico do you think the coyote
is going to be like oh maybe we should
hold this one back yeah what's the fee
to smuggle a taliban across the southern
border well probably more than enough
probably be raising their prices i would
imagine i know in the uk that somebody
that was on the uk's no-fly list
because of terrorism reasons ended up in
the uk correct so they're checking and
they're uh trying to make sure i think
on the remain on mexico thing to me if i
were the biden administration i would
take this as a win
right so you can say to the public and
the progressives like
these trump judges really
that they are terrible and that's why we
need more supreme court justices but
tell breyer to resign but accept the
good outcome yeah my hands are tied by
the law i'm just following the law we
respect institutions
so the afghan disaster obviously he
can't execute anything it reminds
americans degen he can't execute the
border
he can't do anything right
right when we were watching that video
of that child being handed over to
the marine in afghanistan and people
were very upset like we've seen the same
photographs down at the border of
toddlers being dropped
dropped over walls by human traffickers
so again it's just it's the same
disregard for human life and i say it
over and over again
that they've laid the foundation for
people to profit from human suffering
and misery and they're okay with it this
is a but this is a this is how i it does
go to trump's legacy though the number
of judges that he appointed i looked it
up earlier 226 federal judges trump
appointed
54 appeals court judges that was just
one less than obama did in eight years
really i mean this will pay dividends
for years to come thank you cocaine
mitch
and i say that with love
jessica there is a little bit of a
difference between the afghan asylum
seekers and these people crossing the
south
border i mean the people crossing the
southern border have yet to do anything
positive for the united states haven't
done anything at all
asylum seekers coming from afghanistan
they have sometimes literally saved
american lives being translators
spotters drivers but joe biden doesn't
really do much for them hey if you can
make it to the airport good luck
so i i don't see things the same there's
nothing you can say to refute that i i
won greg style i have a lot of notes on
this specifically
um we're a little tight on time
that shocks me the red light just starts
flashing um i actually did hear two
minutes okay so um there are a lot of
people seeking asylum at the southern
border who
have
worked in their home countries and i'm
sure with americans to improve their
quality of life back there for millions
of people who are destitute who are
raped pillaged all the things that are
going to be happening in afghanistan
under the taliban people coming from
central america and it is their legal
right to seek asylum here and they
should go through the process but
of course the interpreters should come
people who fought alongside us but you
shouldn't talk about them like that just
because they're coming from a different
place and hopefully that will get
figured i'm literally hearing hurry up
anyway the point is on the supreme court
ruling it's actually very unclear they
didn't say what the violation actually
was and the policy the remaining mexico
policy hasn't been in place since march
2020 anyway so it seems like secretary
mayorkas can just go back to them with a
more thorough explanation of why they
don't want the remain in mexico policy
they had taken it down because of covid
and to the point about the taliban
people getting here under trump march 20
2020 the peace pact the afghans had to
release 5 000 taliban prisoners in
exchange for only a thousand afghan
prisoners so if there's a taliban
terrorist coming over here to hurt us it
could have been very well released under
president trump but no one talks about
that or you don't talk about that you
talk about it do you talk about it all
the time you won't stop talking about it
i won't stop talking it talking about
anything actually you know you can't
have a border without order and that's
all i'm saying
no actually i'm going to say you know
with rear view mirrors they always say
objects appear closer than they really
are this is another example of the trump
rear-view mirror in that everything in
that mirror seems better now when
compared to
joe being president the trump's policy
of remain in mexico seems like a really
innocuous solution to a problem right
with a you work with mexico over a
poorest border we cooperate
but out of spite and no logic joe killed
that because he killed a lot of things
that were that were related to trump
just because it was trump and he just
dismantled so many important things
uh as a as an irrational response and i
want not just him but the democrats and
the democrat mayors everything that is
that is connected to order whether it's
law enforcement or it's you know foreign
policy how to evacuate people uh um you
know the the border
they just it just crumbles it crumbles
they have no sense of order take the win
take the w says dana perrino
coming up are you kidding me liberal
leaders are bringing back the push for
ready outdoor mask mandates
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else